he's Chris Haynes ESPN NBA reporter one
of our favorites back on the program he
joins us now
hi Chris how are you there's always a
pleasure my god thanks well if the
Warriors win who gets the MVP if the
Warriors win and KD I think yes I think
he has the edge right now but I think
it's between JD and Steph whoever has
the game that is probably the difference
who probably the difference maker with
the contest I think that person but I
picked JD as air that's right now would
these warriors without Durant beat
Cleveland as the Cavaliers are
constructed now yes well I think if
Cleveland yeah this is a you know
special forecast and this would be on a
popular take I don't think they'd be
Cleveland
if the Cavaliers had the roster they had
last year that's just my thing I think
when you look at LeBron what he's doing
now he's we've always talked about him
doing virtually everything on the corner
on both ears but there there's a there's
a there's an extreme distance from
LeBron to the second best player on the
team there was a you know there was a
bit of a difference there with Kyrie but
it wasn't the gap that it is right now
so my belief is I felt like you know
Cleveland would beat him and I thought I
thought that if Katie wasn't on the team
last year I thought Cleveland had his
head shot a bit of him but if you're
okay jitan hypothetical here let's say
Kyrie Irving's healthy and he was still
with the Cavaliers the Cavaliers with
Kyrie Love and LeBron would beat this
Golden State team in your opinion I
would give them the edge of my opinion
look I say this because this when go to
state went after KD you know I was told
that look it was with number 23 and mine
you know it was before because of what
LeBron James provides on the court and
what he can do and when go to state you
know lost that year that was why they
went after Katie to kind of neutralize
LeBron in that role and so
you know dream on green he pretty much
spearheaded you know he was the
mastermind and trying to you know put
all this together and and you know he
got everybody to buy into to go after
Katie and it was with number 23 of mine
so that's why I say that because I feel
like if that was the intention of dream
on green notation you know I'm thinking
this master plan out going out field
they had to let you know he had to I
thought that they didn't have a stand
I wouldn't say stand a great chance but
they he would have to thought think that
the Cavaliers had the heirs with LeBron
so I you know that's the whole reason
this whole Kady libel came about yeah
but if you think if you go back and if
Golden State had closed out the
Cavaliers what Golden State have gone
after Kevin Durant yes okay nice so that
they were going after him no matter okay
all right I'm just curious about that
has Kevin Durant his impact on the NBA
going to Golden State now we can look at
this they're gonna win another
championship here is it good or bad for
basketball what Kevin Durant did for him
personally you know you just say it's
great for you know this is what he
wanted he wanted you know I talked to
him numerous times about this he he
brings it back to this a you days I'm
just playing back all playing with a
group of guys who know how to play the
right way that's one thing that I think
a lot of people miss in OKC you know he
was very frustrated with the style of
play what the hero basketball he wanted
to go out there way uh to just play a
fun free Louisville basketball and
that's what he gets to go to state but
now you talked about for the AP a look I
don't know if it's ever great a great
ideal situation you have a bunch of
superstars on one team and then you have
the rest of this it's not the NFL
there's not a lot of parity out there so
I think for the NBA as a whole it's not
that but at the end of the day we were
looking at the finals we're seeing the
two best teams in the finals four years
in a row but during the regular season
obviously it's diluted so I you know I'm
silver likes the finished product as of
right now I think
he likes what you see it as far as the
ratings at the star personnel all this
stays but during the regular season so
know for a lot of people include the
media include myself to watch talking to
Chris Haynes ESPN NBA reporter why would
LeBron stay in Cleveland after this
finals I don't know why you know it uh
look he's definitely gonna look at you
know look at the landscape see she was
out there but the unfortunate thing for
him is that there's not a lot of teams
out there who first of all I had the cap
and second of all who are you know will
be in position to get him to you know
NBA Finals and the thing about LeBron
like and I heard di was VP I was listen
to you showed earlier he threw out the
scenario of a during a one-year deal and
hitting the market next time I was told
that's that's pretty much not the plans
are right now soon a so it seems as if
so it seems like it will be a multi-year
deal know whatever he decides to do this
summer but would that be a sad EP man he
LeBron LeBron is crafty and whatever he
says everything is premeditated you know
he was asked a couple days about what go
to state brings and he broke down top to
bottom the go to states starting five
strengths compared to his daughter Fox
yeah and he was fair like the guys need
to be go to state the talent you need
the the minds would be on the court and
so you know LeBron is very calculated
he's telling you he's basically let you
know what you need and without saying it
he's letting you know what he doesn't
have so when we when you asking me if
he's going to be back in Cleveland it's
gonna take a complete at Oak close to a
complete overall as possible to get
LeBron to buy here because he wants to
compete for chapter Center and not just
get for the finals every year he wants
to have a chance and I don't think he
has that right
yeah but Chris I'm looking at this
wondering does LeBron want to sign in
trade because if he doesn't sign in
trade he's going to deplete the roster
that he's going to and be further away
from a championship would he leave money
on the table and go to the Lakers or the
Rockets or whoever it might be yes
that's what I don't know that's what I
don't know there but I know for the last
you know last four years ever since he
came back in Cleveland his thing was he
was not going to take a pacer
you know he he was remember he wasn't in
for a long time he was never the
highest-paid player on on his own team
and so when he came back to Cleveland
that was his whole thing look I'm going
to get my true value financially and so
I don't know the answer that but I
haven't right now I would say that I
don't think she's taking the pay cut
anywhere and I think there's there are
teams out there who who will pursue him
that will get creative and trying to
make sure they open up the necessary
cash space to a table good to talk to
you Chris have fun tonight safe travels
after that and we appreciate your time
as always
DPD cop that's Cuisines ESPN NBA
reporter for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]